what about flow induction
you want to flow wisely
and first of all
you you need to understand what flow is
yeah and then you need to confront a
particular issue around a practical
problem around flow let's go there
because a lot of those words seem like
synonyms to people sometimes
so the state of flow
what is it
all right so
um and he just died last year chicks at
mahai i admire him very much we've
exchanged a bunch of messages um over
the past few years and
he wanted to do the podcast several
times
but he's he said his
he struggled with his health and yeah i
i never knew in those situations i
deeply regret um
several cases like this that
um
that i had like with with conway
that i should have pushed him on it
because yeah as you get later in life
things
the simple things become more difficult
but
a voice especially one that hasn't been
really heard is important to hear so
anyway i i apologize but no no i i share
that i mean i can tell you that within
my area he is important and he's famous
in academics in a sense
the flow state
two important sets of conditions and
very often people only talk about one
and that's a little bit of a
misrepresentation
so
the flow state is in situations in which
the demand of the situation is slightly
beyond your skills
so you both have to apply all the skills
you can with as much
sort of attention and concentration
as you possibly can and you have to
actually be stretching your skills
now in this circumstance
people report optimal experience optimal
in two ways optimal in that this is one
of the best experiences i've had in my
life it's distinct from pleasure and yet
it explains why people do very bizarre
things like rock climbing because it's a
good flow induction
right but they also mean optimal in a
second sense my best performance so it's
both the best experience and the best
performance
so chicks at maha also talked about the
information flow conditions you need
right in order for there to be this
state of flow and then i'll talk about
what it's like to be in flow in a sec
what you need is three things
you need the information that you're
getting to be clear it can't be
ambiguous or vague
think about a rock climber if it's
ambiguous and vague you're in trouble
right
there has to be tightly coupled feedback
between what you do and how the
environment responds
so when you act there's an immediate
response there isn't a big time lag
between your action and
your ability to detect the response from
the environment
third failure has to matter
error really matters
so there should be some anxiety about
failure
and failure matters so so that like they
yeah because that's to you the person
that persists yes yes yes
now when you're in the flow state
and notice how this sits on the boundary
between the secular and the sacred
when you're in the flow state yeah
people report a tremendous sense of at
one minute
with the environment
they report a loss of a particular kind
of self-consciousness that narrative
naturing nanny in your head that how do
i look do people like me how do i look
how's my hair do people like me should i
have said that that all goes away
you're free from that you're free from
the most sadistic super ego self-critic
you could possibly have at least for a
while
the world is vivid
it's super salient to you there's an
ongoing sense of discovery
although often you know you're exerting
a lot of metabolical metabolical effort
it feels effortless so
in the flow state when you're sparring
your hand just goes up for the block and
you you your strike just goes through
the empty space or if you're a goalie in
hockey i got to mention hockey once i'm
a canadian right
you put out your you know you put out
your glove hand and the puck's there
right
so there's this tremendous
sense of
grace
at one minute
super salience discovery and
realness
people don't well people don't when
they're in the flow state they don't go
i bet this is an illusion
the interesting questions for me and my
co-authors in the book in the
the article we published in the hamburg
the ha the oxford handbook a spontaneous
thought with aryan harry bennett and leo
ferraro is that's a descriptive account
of flow we wanted an explanatory account
what are the causal mechanisms at work
inflow
and so
we actually proposed to interlocking
cognitive processes
the first thing we said is well
what's going on in flow
well think about it think about the rock
climber
the rock climber and we i talked about
this earlier they they're constantly
restructuring how they're seeing the
rock face
they're constantly doing something like
insight
and if they and if they fail to do it
they impass and that starts to get
dangerous so they got to do an insight
that primes an insight that primes an
insight so imagine the aha experience
that that flash and that moment and
imagine it cascading so you're getting
the extended aha that's why things are
super salient there's a sense of
discovery there's a sense of at one
minute of deep participation of grace
but there's something else going on too
so there's a phenomena called implicit
learning
also very well replicated
starts way back in the 60s with reba
you can give people complex patterns
like
number and letter strings
right
and
they can learn about those patterns
outside of deliberate focal awareness
that's why it's called implicit learning
and what's interesting is if you try and
change that task into
um
you know tell me the pattern but
explicitly to
explicitly try to figure out their
performance to grades
so here's the idea you have this
adaptive capacity for implicit learning
and what it does is it results in you
being able to track complex variables
in a way but you don't know how you came
up with that knowledge
right so you get and this is hogarth's
proposal in educating intuition
intuition is actually the result of
implicit learning so an example i use is
how far do you stand away from somebody
at a funeral
there's a lot of complex variables
there's status closeness to the person
you're a relationship to them past
history all kinds of stuff
and yet you know how to do it and you
didn't have to go to funeral school
i'm just using that as an example so you
have these powerful intuitions now
here's hogarth's great point
implicit learning remember i said before
the things that make it adaptive make us
subject to self-deception here's another
example implicit learning is powerful at
picking up on complex patterns but it
doesn't care what kind of pattern it is
it doesn't distinguish
causal patterns
from merely correlational patterns
so implicit learn when we like it it's
intuition when it's picking up on stuff
that's bogus we call it prejudice or all
kinds of other names for intuition
that's going wrong
now he said okay what do we do
what do we do about this and this will
get back to flow what do we do about
this well we can't try to replace
implicit learning with explicit learning
because we'll lose all the adaptiveness
to it so what can we do explicitly what
we can do is take care of the
environment in which we're doing the
implicit learning
how do we do that we try to make sure
the environment has features that help
us distinguish causation from
correlation
what kind of environments have we
created that are good at distinguishing
causation from correlation
experimental environments
what do you do in an experiment you make
sure that the variables are clear no
confound no ambiguity no vagueness you
make sure there's a tight coupling
between the independent and the
dependent variable and your hypothesis
can be falsified error matters now look
at those three legs those are exactly
the three conditions that you need for
flow
clear information tightly coupled
feedback and error matters
so flow is not only an insight cascade
improving your insight capacity it's
also
a marker that you're
you're you're cultivating the best kind
of intuitions the ones that fit you best
to the causal patterns in your
environment
but it's hard to achieve that kind of
environment
where there's a clear distinction
between causality and correlation and
and it has this
the the rigor of a scientific experiment
fair enough
and i don't think hogarth was saying
it's going to be epistemically as
rigorous as a scientific experiment but
he's saying
right if you structure that it will tend
to do what that scientific method does
which is fine think of the rock climber
all of those things are the case they
need clear information
right it's tightly coupled and error
matters and they think what they're
doing is very real because if they're
not if they're not you know conforming
to the real causal patterns of the rock
face and the physiology of their body
they will fall
is there something
to be said about the power of
discovering meaning and having this deep
relationship with the
with the moment
there's something about flow that's
really
forgets the past and the future yes and
it's really focused on the moment i
think that's part of the phenomenology
but i think the functionality has to do
with the fact that what's happening in
flow is that dynamic
non-propositional connectedness that is
so central to meaning
is being optimized this is why flow is a
good predictor
of the how well you rate your life
how much well-being you
you think you have which of course is
itself also predictive and interrelated
with how meaningful you find your life
one of the things that you can do but
there's an important caveat
to increase your sense of meaning in
life is to get into the flow state more
frequently that's why i said you you
want a moving practice that's conducive
to the flow state but there's one
important caveat
which is
we of course have figured out and i'm
playing with words here how to game this
and how to hijack it by creating things
like video games i'm not saying this is
the case for all video games or this is
the case for all people but the who now
acknowledges this as a real thing
that you can get into the flow state
within the video game world
to the detriment of your ability to get
into the flow state in the real world
what's the opposite of flow
depression in fact depression has been
called anti-flow
so you get these people they're flowing
in this non-real world
and it's
they can't transfer it to the real world
and it's actually costing them flow in
the real world so they tend to get they
tend to suffer depression and all kinds
of things oh your ability your uh habit
and just skill at attaining flow in the
video game world
basically
makes you less effective
or maybe shocks you at how difficult it
is to achieve flow in the physical world
yeah i'm not sure about this i just i
don't i don't want to push back against
the implied
challenge of transferability
because um
you know there's a lot of you know i
have
a lot of friends that play video games a
lot a very large percent of young folks
play video games and
i'm
hesitant to build up models
uh of how that affects behavior my
intuition is weak there oftentimes
people that have phds are of a certain
age that they came up when video games
weren't a deep part of their life
development i would venture to say
people who have developed their brain
with video games being a part a large
part of that world
are in some sense different humans
and it's possible that they can transfer
more effectively some of the lessons
um
some of the ability to attain flow from
the virtual world to the physical world
they're also more i would venture to say
resilient to the negative effects
of for example social media or
or video games they have
that you know maybe the objectification
or like the over-sexualized or violent
aspect of video games they're able to
turn that off when they go to the
physical world and turn it back on when
they're playing
the video games probably more
effectively than
um
the the old-timers so i just want to say
sort of
i'm not sure it's a really interesting
question how transferable the flow state
is
i don't know if there's if you want to
comment on it i do i do um first of all
i did qualify and i'm saying it's not
all the case for all video games or for
all people i'm holding out the
possibility and i know this possibility
because uh i've had students who
actually suffer from this and have done
work uh around it with me um the the
ability to digest they couldn't they
couldn't transfer yeah
um and then they were able to step back
from that and then take up the cognitive
science and write about it and work on
it
also
i'm not so sure about the resiliency
claim because
there seems to be
mounting evidence it's not
consensus
but it's certainly not regarded as
fringe
that the increase in social media is
being is pretty strongly correlated with
increase in depression self-destructive
behavior uh things like this i would
like to see that evidence because
no no no no
let me um
i'm always hesitant
to to eagerly kind of agree with things
that i want to agree with that there's a
public perception everyone seems to hate
on social media
i i
i wonder as always with these things
does it reveal
depression or does it create depression
sure this is always the question it's
like
uh whenever you talk about any political
or ideological movement does it create
hate
or does it reveal hate and that's a good
thing to ask and you should always
challenge the things that you
intuitively want to believe i agree with
that um
like aliens
so one of the ways you address this and
it's not it's not sufficient and i did
say that work is preliminary but you you
if if i can give you a plausible
mechanism
that's new
and then that lends credence and part of
what happens right is illusory social
comparison
uh think of instagram people are posting
things that are not accurate
representation of their life or life
events in fact they will stage things
but we what the people that are looking
at these right they take it often as
real and so they get downward social
comparison uh and this is and
and this is like
compared to
how you and i probably live we may get
one or two of those events a week
they're getting them moment by moment
and so it's a plausible mechanism that
why it might be driving people into a
more depressed state so okay the flip
side of that
is because there's a greater greater gap
going from real world to instagram world
you start to be able to laugh at it and
realize that it's artificial so for
example even just artificial filters
people start to realize like yeah
there's like
it's the same kind of gap as there is
between the video game world and the
real world in the video game world you
can do all kinds of wild things
uh grand theft auto you can shoot people
up you can do whatever the heck you want
in the real world you can't and you
start to develop
an understanding of how to have fun in
the virtual world and in the physical
world and i think it's just a push back
i'm not saying either is true though
yeah those are very interesting claims
the more ridiculously out of touch
instagram becomes
the easier you can laugh it off
potentially in terms of the effect it
has on your site i'll respond to that
but at some point we should get back to
flow
as we engage in flow you laugh at the
the hair the shampoo commercial
you buy the shampoo
yeah
there's a capacity for tremendous
bullshitting because of the way these
machines are designed to trigger
salience without triggering reflective
truth-seeking
i'm thinking of counter examples uh
because you're
sometimes you're
uh can laugh all the way to the bank so
you could you can laugh and not buy the
shampoo right there's there's many cases
so i think you have to laugh hard enough
you do have to laugh hard enough but
the advertising the advertisers get
millions of dollars precisely because
for many many people it does make you
buy the shampoo and that's the concern
and maybe the machine of social media is
such that optimizes the shampoo buying
yes the point i was trying to make is
whether or not that particular example
is you know
ultimately right the possibility of
transfer
failure is a real thing
um and i want to contrast that
to an experience i had when i was in
grad school i've been doing tai chi
chuan about
three or four years very religiously in
both senses the word like three or four
hours a day
and like reading all the literature and
like
i was having all the weird experiences
you know cold as ice hot as lava all
that stuff and it's ooh right
but my friends in grad school
they said to me
what's what what's going on you're
different
and i said what do you mean
and they said
well you're a lot more balanced in your
interactions and you're a lot more
flowing and you're a lot more sort of
flexible and you adjust more and i
realized oh
you know and this was this was the sort
of taoist claim around tai chi chuan
that
it actually transfers
in ways that
you might not expect you start to be
able
and i've now noticed that i now notice
how how i'm doing tai chi even in this
interaction and how it can facilitate
and afford and so there's a
powerful transfer and that's what i
meant by you know flow wisely not only
flow in a way that's right making sure
that you're
distinguishing causation from
correlation which flow can do
but
find how to situate it home it so that
it will percolate through your psyche
and permeate through many domains of
your life
you